raúl es buenos días efectivamente estoy
frente al partido agrupación nacional
hace algunos minutos nada más marín
salió de aquí no hay tiempo que perder
ella lo sabe está viendo esta
presidencia muy muy cerca por lo tanto
hoy trabajo con todo su equipo de
campaña y esta tarde ya se va a
desplazar al campo a una explotación de
cereales para hablar justamente sobre el
poder adquisitivo esos cereales tan
tocados por la guerra en ucrania ya se
ha anunciado también que habrá dos actos
grandes de campaña uno esta semana en
avignon y la próxima en arranz y el
resto del tiempo ella lo va a dedicar a
ir al contacto de la gente como usted
decía muy bien en ese reportaje y ha
cambiado su imagen y se muestra como la
candidata cercana al pueblo en contraste
con el presidente manuel matrona el
presidente liberal el presidente de los
ricos ella ha puesto esta segunda vuelta
como un referéndum contra el gobierno de
manuel macro y otra cosa muy importante
es preparar también el debate de este
segundo de esta segunda vuelta de las
presidenciales raúl que fue su gran
punto débil en el año 2017 sobre todo el
manejo de las cifras por lo mismo
durante la campaña ya habló
concretamente cómo iba a ser para todas
esas medidas de tintes populistas que
ella propone justamente para mejorar el
poder adquisitivo de los franceses así
que se va a preparar también dos días de
esta semana nos va a dedicar con su
equipo de campaña a preparar bien ese
enfrentamiento con el actual presidente
francés